[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur France 24
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
la durée de la transition en Guinée au
menu des discussions entre les autorités
guinéennes et une délégation de la
Cedeao le médiateur de l'organisation
régionale a fait le déplacement à
Conakry Thomas Bonnie espère parvenir à
une réduction de la durée de transition
on parlera également des inondations au
Niger qui ont tué au moins 192 personnes
en quelques semaines à Zinder des
centaines d'hectares ont été ravagés la
récolte s'annonce difficile dans la
région reportage d'hall de Girard dans
ce journal
et puis nous irons au Togo où le cancer
du sein représente un tiers des cancers
chez les femmes en ce mois d'Octobre
Rose nous nous intéresserons à leur
situation dans un pays où les soins sont
hors de prix ce qui entraîne une hausse
des décès du haut cancer du sein
reportage à suivre
on ouvre ce journal avec cette visite du
médiateur de la CEDEAO en Guinée Thomas
Boni est arrivé mardi à Conakry sa
mission convaincre les autorités
guinéennes de revoir la durée de
transition qu'elles ont établies à 3 ans
en mai dernier l'organisation régionale
a donné un mois à la Guinée pour
proposer une durée plus raisonnable sous
peine de sanctions les précisions de
notre correspondant à Conakry Malik
Diakité
baisse son arrivée la délégation de la
Cedeao a rencontré le ministre des
Affaires étrangères et le chef du
gouvernement guinéen au cours de cette
première échanges bernago mot le Premier
ministre guinéen a expliqué que son
gouvernement je cite n'était pas figé
sur la question de la durée de la
transition cette durée c'est la
contentieux majeur entre les militaires
au pouvoir qui optent pour une
transition de trois ans trop longue pour
la CEDEAO qui exige deux ans selon le
médiateur de la CEDEAO les lignes Bose
entre les différentes parties tout le
monde se félicite de l'évolution de
discussion je crois que l'espoir est
permis il n'y a pas d'inquiétude les
soins permets et la Cedeo est vraiment
décidé à faire en sorte
que la paix en Guinée de mon âge que ce
pays
prenne son envoi dans un climat
démocratique que de ce point de vue la
disposés sont des prises et que cette
manière que cette transition se fasse
dans le calme en septembre la Cedeo a
décrété des sanctions progressives
contre les militaires guinéens au
pouvoir notamment le gel des avoir à
financier l'interdiction de voyage ainsi
que la suspension de toute assistance et
transactions financière en faveur de la
Guinée par les institutions financières
de la CEDEAO elle a aussi donné un mois
aux militaire pour réduire la durée de
la transition sous peine de subir de
nouvelles sanctions plus sévères la date
butoir de cette avertissement de la
CEDEAO tombe justement ce samedi 22
octobre
au Niger la saison des pluies touche à
sa fin avec l'espoir que les inondations
se résorbent elles ont déjà fait près de
200 morts ces dernières semaines un
drame humain mais aussi certainement un
dramagricole puisque des centaines
d'hectares ont été ravagés par les eaux
la région la plus touchée et celle de
Zinder regardez ce reportage de notre
correspondant au Niger à rôle de Girard
pour accéder au village d'angoisseulu un
véhicule motorisé est inutile les
inondations ne laissent passer que les
charrettes sur place c'est un village
fantôme que nous découvrons presque tous
les habitants fuient les intempéries les
pires depuis plusieurs décennies à en
guadeloup on n'a jamais connu de tels
inondations vraiment on n'a jamais connu
ça
dans la région de Zinder plus de 90 000
personnes sont sinistrées plus de 500
hectares agricoles sont détruits
tous nos champs sont ici tous nos champs
sont immergés jusqu'au prochain village
ce sont nos champs ils sont détruits il
y a un de nos greniers ici à notre la si
on pouvait y accéder on aurait récupéré
une partie de la récolte
en guadeloup est situé dans une cuvette
est une zone particulièrement inondable
une large partie des 396 familles du
village ont exprimé aux agents du
Programme alimentaire mondial ne pas
vouloir y retourner
et les sols et l'eau et elle n'est pas
perméable donc ce qui fait
deux qui a eu des fortes précipitations
donc on a la stagnation d'eau et du coup
comment les matériaux de construction ne
sont pas adaptées donc c'est ça qui
amène la destruction l'inondation les
habitants ont trouvé refuge à quelques
centaines de mètres sur une parcelle
prêtée par un agriculteur de la région
le PAM alerte son action humanitaire a
été fragilisée au Niger en 2022
avec la rareté des ressources on s'est
retrouvé à réduire le financement à
réduire l'assistance alimentaire donc
nécessairement les enfants qui ont l'âge
de moins de 2 ans ont besoin d'une
supplémentation nutritionnelle pour
renforcer quand même leur état
nutritionnel et leur état de santé
également début octobre le Programme
alimentaire mondial annonçait que 48
millions de dollars de budget
supplémentaires seraient nécessaire pour
continuer ses missions urgentes au Niger
jusqu'en mars 2023
et les Tchadiens n'ont pas été épargnés
eux non plus par les pluies qui se sont
abattus ces derniers jours dans la
région des centaines de milliers de
sinistrés ont été recensés des camps de
fortune ont été installés à ne jamais na
ils peuvent accueillir jusqu'à 2000
personnes dans la capitale les habitants
se sont organisés pour faire face aux
inondations on en écoute quelques-uns
cette nuit l'inondation a commencé on a
sifflé pour demander de l'aide on a
ramassé des objets pour nous barricader
mais jusqu'à ce matin nous étions
submergés nous sommes toujours dans
l'eau et nous n'avons plus de force
de mettre la tête dans les sac pour
fabriquer la digue pour empêcher l'eau
qui est en train de prendre l'hôpital
l'attention entre la France et le Mali
toujours vivent le ministre malien des
Affaires étrangères a déclaré devant le
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU que le
gouvernement exercerait son droit à se
défendre si je cite la France continuait
à porter atteinte à la souveraineté la
sécurité du Mali Abdoulaye Diop a
renouvelé les accusations selon
lesquelles la France aurait violé
l'espace aérien malien est livré des
armes à des combattants islamistes la
France ni ses accusations
François Hollande qui était chef de
l'État en 2013 quand l'opération Serval
a été déclenchée regrette ces tensions
il parle de régression notre
correspondant au Maroc Jean-Marie
Lemaire l'a rencontré en marge d'une
conférence contre la corruption à Rabat
on écoute l'ancien président de la
République
grave que la France qui avait été
appelée elle n'est pas venue de son
propre chef elle est pas c'est pas
imposée que la France était conduite à
quitter le Mali et la solidarité qu'elle
devait à l'égard de la population et ça
a été provoqué on le sait par les coups
d'État par aussi des manœuvres notamment
russes qui ont laissé entendre que la
France cherchait je ne sais quel intérêt
résultat aujourd'hui la France notamment
au Mali est parti même si elle est
encore présente dans les pays de la
région et on envoie les conséquences la
population civile connaît des massacres
les djihadistes progressent s'installent
des villes qui étaient libérées de ce
fléau et bien retombe sous cette coupe
et donc nous avons de ce point de vue un
sentiment non pas d'échec parce que les
forces françaises ont fait leur travail
mais un sentiment de régression
ce prix qui récompense notre reporter
Clément dit Roma anciennement
correspondant Centrafrique qu'il
remporte avec Carole Valade
correspondant à RFI le prix Daphné car
on a Galicia pour le journalisme ils
sont tous les deux récompensés pour leur
travail d'enquête sur l'influence russe
et celle des mercenaires de Wagner en
Centrafrique leur reportage a été publié
dans le journal Le Monde il a aussi été
diffusé sur la chaîne Arte et dans
l'émission reporter sur France 24
extrait de ce reportage
dans ces quartiers de Bangui règne le
sentiment d'être abandonné par la France
l'ancienne puissance colonisatrice
interro fertile pour implanter de
nouvelles idées
financé par les Russes et par le
gouvernement trésor et ses camarades
organisent des rassemblements en soutien
à Moscou
[Musique]
la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui n'est pas la
jeunesse d'hier
les choses il y a constamment
dans les pays mais aujourd'hui on croit
moins avec ce que la Russie a fait chez
nous on n'a pas besoin de faire un
calcul donc c'est à nous les jeunes de
prendre les devants de ces choses
le discours prorus est bien rodé et les
éléments de langage affûté en main en
outre drapeau tricolore qui remplace
celui des Français
dans l'histoire si on revient on arrête
l'histoire témoin que la Russie n'a
jamais causé un pays africain nous on
n'est pas contre la France mais c'est la
mauvaise politique de la France qui nous
fait qui nous fait du mal nous avons
fait combien d'années avec la France
regardez l'état du pays nous avons connu
combien de coups d'État c'est beaucoup
combien de mutinerie on a perdu combien
de président de la République et
aujourd'hui avec la présence russe dans
un laps de temps nous avons un bon
résultat et ça m'a poussé ça m'a donné
un engagement ferme à soutenir là aussi
parce que ce que nous voulons c'est pas
c'est le bien-être non c'est la libre
circulation aujourd'hui ici on a la
sécurité les jeunes peuvent aller à
l'école nous avons on peut valider et ça
nous le voyons pour le moment c'est
pourquoi ça m'a donné le courage et
l'envie de tenir le gaborus pour dire
merci à la Russie merci au présent
Poutine
et vous pouvez retrouver leur travail
sur notre site internet rubrique
reporter
en ce mois d'Octobre rose on va
s'intéresser à la situation des femmes
au Togo qui souffrent du cancer du sein
le cancer le plus répandu dans le pays
il représente un cas sur trois chez les
togolaises le coût du traitement est
élevé et il n'est pas entièrement pris
en charge par la couverture de santé
universelle ce qui explique une
augmentation des décès puisqu'elles sont
nombreuses à ne pas avoir des moyens de
se soigner regardez ce reportage
d'Emmanuel soggi et Raphaël
qui réside à Lomé la capitale du Togo
s'affaiblit de jour en jour en raison
d'un cancéreux sain lui provoquant
d'intenses douleurs au bras une douleur
chronique depuis qu'elle ne peut plus
poursuivre son traitement après
l'ablation d'un sein
[Applaudissements]
si c'est
les moyens on a même pas mis un bras le
bras de Darko continue c'est
l'équivalent de 4500 euros cette femme
s'est endettée pour financer son
opération avec un mari également malade
impossible à eux deux de faire face aux
charges quotidiennes une association lui
apporte
occasionnellement des produits de
première nécessité ces de l'injustice
sociale
c'est un descriptible ce qu'elle vivent
ces femmes elles vivent un drame et
souvent on regarde certaines femmes
comme ça jusqu'à ce que on nous annonce
que elles sont décédées 20 % des malades
souffrant du cancer ne peuvent pas
terminer leur traitement le nouveau
système public d'assurance maladie mis
en place l'année dernière ne couvre pas
la totalité des traitements
anticancéreux même chose du côté des
compagnies d'assurance la femme de cet
homme est soignée du cancer du sein
depuis septembre dernier après
l'ablation d'un saint elle a aujourd'hui
sa première séance de chimiothérapie
c'est vraiment difficile surtout que
c'est extrêmement coûteux surtout nous
n'avons pas une assurance maladie qui
puisse nous rembourser c'est vrai la
société impliquée dans la lutte contre
le cancer plaide pour une subvention de
la prise en charge et la mise à
disposition de la radiothérapie dans le
public car aujourd'hui encore il faut se
soigner dans le privé pour bénéficier
des machines dernier cri on a obligé des
fois de traiter à des prix sociaux avec
ses plus sociaux vous tournons
réellement à perdre l'OMS s'estime que
les cas de cancer ne cesseront
d'augmenter en Afrique subsaharienne en
raison de l'insuffisance des ressources
consacrées à leur prévention au Togo il
n'y a pas encore de budget spécifique
pour lutter contre les cancers alors que
presque 70% des malades en meurent
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve à
22h45 pour un nouveau journal de
l'Afrique à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
septembre 2002 le Jul la Ferrié
effectuant la navette entre Dakar et
Ziguinchor en Casamance sombre sous le
poids de ses passagers
n'étaient pas opérationnel